I feel like my dog could run Canada
[Music]
I'm Sam talent and I'm here to answer
the internet if you had to go to war
would you choose to go during the Middle
Ages the Revolutionary War or in World
War One I'd go to the one that had tanks
and guns I'm not going to make it
running across a mud strewn Battlefield
if it's me now as I am in the middle
ages of the Revolutionary War they're
going to be hunting me like a Golem
because I'm the biggest man they've ever
seen and I know more than 12 words so
I'm gonna go and lock the door yeah yeah
who put the note in his mouth yeah yeah
no they would just be chasing me with
pitchforks so yeah World War one because
you're gonna die in a gassing if you're
lucky if you only had five dollars to
get drunk what would you buy I would buy
Everclear because then no matter what
happens
you don't care you've been anesthetized
to the world and probably ruined every
relationship so being as broke as you
were to get five dollars worth of booze
doesn't matter anymore because you
probably cheated on your wife with your
sister at that point because you're
blasted on Everclear
yeah would you rather know when you're
going to die or how you're going to die
I would much rather know when I'm going
to die so I can do everything that I
need to beforehand not knowing how I'm
going to die
heart disease at 53.
cool all right well yeah no [__]
Professor thank you if you're coming
down from your Cloud to give me this
yeah I want to know when I'm going to
die so I can get all my [__] in before I
go out and also like you know with like
10 days out before you're going to die
let it [__] it oh yeah because also you
can do whatever you want if you know
that's the date of your death you can't
change that it's been ordained right so
you can like jump in front of trains and
stuff you know what I mean you can jump
off of buildings at that point but maybe
you were then put in a wheelchair you're
still alive but you're in some kind of
breathing device I just like to know the
exact date and that's fine and
everything else before that is just I
can do whatever I want it doesn't care
who I hurt because I know that I'm dying
how long out would you want to know are
you tell me right now and if you give me
any time past 60 it's borrowed time baby
that's all gravy on the biscuit yeah if
you won 300 million what are the first
three things you're going to buy
um a gun ammunition and an airplane
because people are going to be coming at
me
I'm gonna go to an island and just shoot
anyone who comes to shore my deadbeat
friends ooh a lot of people need
operations you know yeah [__] that dude
I am seceding from society I'm bringing
my wife and three of her hottest friends
[Laughter]
only gonna make love with my wife
I'm gonna get in trouble
with a warm-up how fast could you throw
a fastball on an MLB Mound three what
does the warm-up include an operation
where they attach a new arm to me
is that part of the warm-up I would be
completely humiliated if I was put on
any Mound whether it be an MLB pitching
mound or like an ancient indigenous
burial mound nothing good is going to
happen to me on top of a mount the best
thing that happens is I roll down the
mound and my dick and balls are exposed
that's that's my pants rip yeah it's 500
years from now and you're the person in
charge of naming this era what would you
call it a miracle if there is a
possibility to name 500 years from now
and it's not just the last remaining
humans Trading
trading their holes for salt and water
like yeah I wouldn't call it the Gilded
Age that's for sure yeah you mean the
era where come is currency yeah yeah
God would you rather a get paid 1
million a year to have to work
ridiculous hours or get paid 100 000 a
year for doing nothing I'm a comedian so
B
yeah I'm already living B right now yeah
things are going well yeah
I want to represent you in a trial by
combat I'd want a [__] Sumo dude I'd
want someone who represented me not just
in combat but also in life you know or
Ray Lewis
give me Ray Lewis because we know that
he won't stop again allegedly if you had
to win a game show to stay alive which
game show would you choose I would
choose Jeopardy because I think that I
would not lose Jeopardy I would come in
second for sure in Jeopardy I would
choose College Jeopardy because they
[__] spoon feed it to those Rich Kids
Celebrity Jeopardy yes I could dominate
that half cocked on that Everclear from
previous oh my God Celebrity Jeopardy is
I mean I know we don't use certain words
anymore but the ones we used to describe
the level of question in Celebrity
Jeopardy because those are just
embarrassing oh yeah I would crush
Liberty Jeopardy you give me Demi Lovato
you give me Pete Davidson and me
they're going into the grinder I play
Jeopardy with my wife and like my
friends and they look at me like I'm
rain man yeah so how many
so I've done the Jeopardy chess very
test various times online and have
qualified but until May of last year I
didn't have a college degree so you had
to like to be a college that's what
that's what they said discriminatory I
know yeah but then I went and finally
got it at Metro State University home of
the road runners
yeah what what made you do that uh my
mom died I was like I always promised
her I would get my degree
yeah I know dude yeah she was looking up
at me smiling yeah dude Celebrity
Jeopardy easy I would crush that how
much money would it take for you to give
up your favorite food for the rest of
your life
uh
140 dollars but it would it would I
would live so much longer about all the
other Foods I could eat well you could
just do that now I could but no one's
paying me write me out a check boys all
right you guys are doing okay what would
it be oh it would be a delicious pho
noodle soup but I drink the broth
apparently that's sodium Laden and
you're not supposed to do that I'm
married to a doctor whenever I drink the
broth she's like how does that life
insurance policy
actually unbelievable the next question
on top is yeah your girlfriend keeps
nagging you to get healthy and go to the
gym with her pass would you lose a few
pounds or break up with her oh I'd lose
a few pounds a few pounds wow because
we're in the bathroom we I pissed out
three pounds yeah yeah
dude yeah I had I had maybe 35 Miller
lights over the last three days a few
pounds is just me getting into Sonic I
love my wife you know hard she rode for
me yeah I can't lose 50 lbs for the old
lady oh I'd do anything
except except for that thing you wanted
to do in Aspen honey he wasn't that
handsome would you rather see everything
that has occurred in the history of the
world or everything that's going to
happen in the future oh take out
gambling gambling I would much rather
see what's going to happen because the
entire history of the all of human
history was very boring for a long time
I feel like I have a pretty good
understanding of that I want to see just
how rapid and awful the fall off of
humanity is going to be I'd like to be
doing it from a separate area where I
can just view it omnipotently as opposed
to like being out there you know yeah
fighting for a knife in the mud yeah
yeah and the calm dude I hope it's calm
is a lot more nutritional value income
than mud
from like 50 years we're all going to be
eating both we'll be glad to have it
if you could pick one country to run
what would it be oh
I would love to be at the helm of France
oh my Lord I'm so just enamored with
France I strongly disagree with that
really the French love to protest yeah I
know I like that I love Revolution
no no because I'd give them whatever
they want I'd be spineless at the helmet
yeah yeah I'd be like hey guys the
president prime minister what do they
have they've got a they've got a
beautiful city over there in Paris yeah
what they have is the best croissants
I've ever had yeah
play and I wouldn't want to run this one
right this this clown car we're in I
feel like my dog could run Canada
I feel like that one itself so maybe
Canada
he made a couple of whoopsies in his
past you know he wanted to fit in a new
kennel
thank you for watching Anthony in that
please subscribe to the channel comment
below on other celebrities you'd like to
see and make sure you hit the Bell to
get notifications when new episodes come
out